but I wanted to to say two things the
number one let's try to think about
education expansively and let's define
the education sector as expensively as
possible this isn't part prompted by the
wonderful work that our British
colleagues are doing you know as I said
the other day you can do almost anything
if you push hard within the education
sectors in Britain you cannot bring
certain things to the public because of
royalty issues and I don't think we've
pushed it to that extent here but it's
an issue enough to come to terms with us
as Mara just stated quite eloquently
many students never enter a classroom
we're all living longer education
doesn't end we're realizing that MIT
long ago with OpenCourseWare realized
their students come from all across the
world many researchers and investigators
are unaffiliated there's this thing
that's becoming quite an issue now to
citizen science citizen scientists have
always played a significant role in
ornithology in astronomy you know
shoemaker-levy which I guess it's
leaving was an amateur astronomer I've
seen him speak but I forgot which one
mathematics for hundreds of years and
I'm these are just a few examples my
spouse is a wildlife rehabilitator this
is a field that's made up mostly of
working-class rural women they publish a
peer-reviewed journal and a bunch of
people have contributed to a
peer-reviewed text that black well as
publishing these are minimum wage
workers for the most part who wouldn't
be able to afford to buy the book but
they're gonna get a masters copy and
they're the kind of people that need
access to the latest and the best
educational material I myself was just a
beneficiary last year of a melon grant
through the National Film Preservation
to do the field guide to sponsored films
I needed to do two thousand ProQuest
searches to to pull together detail from
my book I'm not a scholar them not an
affiliated scholar the san francisco
public library only gets the times and
they'll cut you off after a while and
they I think a license for one user many
many situations like that we know that
the educational system is broken in many
places the fixes are parallel they're
not serial we need to make the basic
source materials open and available to
all it's one way to get closer to an
even playing field so I'm hoping that
one thing that comes out of this is that
we don't make deals that are just for
the ads sector we don't even know what
that is right now and it's elitist and
potentially ruin us to draw lines so two
lawyers licensors and distributors in
this room out of this room where um
we're once in this room I would hope
that we can write language that clears
content for education in every form of
media all venues locations territories
and contexts maybe we can monkey wrench
it somehow so that education becomes
universal we need to quit making
education a special interest is really
what I'm saying and point to this has
been a tremendous conference I've
learned quite a lot and there's through
this amazing array of efforts that are
proceeding in parallel towards what
appears to be a common goal my question
is what is the common goal many of us
most of us are here to report on
particular projects or particular
interests that admittedly point in a
certain direction and share a commonly
held assumptions and many of these
projects have reached the execution
stage it's very cool these are not you
know demo demo proofs but i think that
with a few exceptions most of us are
working on details of a very big picture
and i worry that the big objective is
receding into the distance it continues
to recede um so this morning talking
with Paul Gerhardt before he left he
said put it this way
and he was right what would what would
we do if we were building public
television from scratch today if this
was day one of public television or as
they call it in England public service
broadcasting which is different than
better could we build a TV service that
was totally open to all from day one and
then at the same time could we visualize
and execute the parallel project which
is to free everything that's ever been
made more of us probably want to free
archives than to keep them locked up but
we are all waiting for permission and I
would submit that no great leap forward
has ever occurred with permission from
everybody involved it just doesn't
happen somebody's going to have to
disobey and let the world catch up as
best as it can and perhaps a lot of
institutions would consider disobedience
at the same time so they need to walk
together to free everything that we call
etv and PTV is a culture on social act
of the highest importance and we need to
frame it that way it's not an academic
project it's not a research grant it's
not a site that reaches just a few
hundred thousand people we're all doing
cool stuff but it's very hard to frame
these projects individually as world
changing and we need to get the kind of
attention I said a little bit about this
this morning that Google God when it's
said a no for that it's going to scan
books and five great libraries front
page of the times um major freakout in a
research library field totally change
the agenda reframe the agenda that next
morning you know I canceled errs and
Provost's and ul's and probably a
hundred small schools started
fantasizing that they could save a lot
of money by closing their staffs dumping
books because it was all going to be on
Google change the paradigm and
interestingly enough it seems evident
that Google didn't know very much about
how it was going to do this at the time
of that announcement and they they'd
only done a few books and they had
hardly
anything in place in terms of contract
but they threw the gauntlet down to the
world as did YouTube perhaps not
expecting to do so when it became the
world's default Media archive as as did
Napster was just just Nathan pointed out
so I can't leave I've been interested in
archival access for a long time and I
was just looking for little raises to
cannibalize from my laptop and there's a
paper that I wrote in 1993 about why we
should open up archives I was not the
only one that's too long and I really
hope that we could maybe find some
leaders that are willing to disobey and
that's my my piece thank you